all right tim tim oh where'd you grow up
where are you from originally i was born
in saint pete florida
st petersburg which is neighbor we're in
tampa right now yeah so it's across the
across the bay yeah it's uh it's where
the
ray's stadium is and yeah and tell me
about how you grew up
uh i grew up pretty good i grew up
you know when i was real little we
weren't
you know we didn't have money we were
lower considered more or less lower
class
my dad was a record producer and then
he was trying to do that off and on and
then we moved out to uh
san francisco for a little bit him and
my mom were climbing telephone poles he
got into the telecommunications industry
so
lived out there for about two years and
then moved back here to clearwater
and uh went to elementary school at uh
one or two private schools through like
preschool and kindergarten first grade
christian you know christian type
schools and uh
you know after that went to regular
public school elementary school
um you know had a good childhood for the
most part i mean
wasn't anything spectacular you know
until we started to get into middle
school
and my dad hit it big with one of the
bands that he produced locally
and uh you know got some money we
were able to move into a bigger house
and then he got into the
telecommunications industry
and to you know uh call centers
basically yeah and you uh you got your
high school
i got through part of high school i mean
i played football
all growing up so i was you know really
into sports i was quarterback
starting quarterback all through
elementary and middle school but
once i had like 14 you know went into
high school
you know i let the immaturity and what
not run wild for
a kid and was interested in girls and
partying and all that stuff so
that started to lead me down a bad road
well i started out smoking pot
here and there um and then
you know slowly moved into lsd and
mushrooms and roofies this was back in
the 90s so
times were a little bit different back
then there wasn't the internet and
everything like there is now but you
know and i lived in a
nice suburb area that you know was uh
you know more middle to upper class and
so there was really nothing to do out
there
as this is over in palm harbor across
the way so
um i just had too much time on my hands
you know
wasn't making the grades in school so i
didn't play high school football like i
wanted to
and started slipping more off into
partying and getting in trouble
got kicked out of school in ninth grade
had to you know go
and move to illinois to finish
my ninth grade year so that i could stay
on track
with uh you know the rest of
my classmates so did that came back you
know did good for a little bit but then
met a girl that was a senior when i was
a sophomore she was going off to
tallahassee to school
so i ended up dropping out getting my
ged
going to college when i was 16 which
looking back now i would have
stayed in high school and knowing what i
know now obvious hindsight's always 20
20 but
i would have you know stayed in high
school and not
followed that path but i did that and
you know
when i was up there i was given so much
money and had a dorm
dorm room that was paid for but i wanted
to go and do my own thing i was in a
college town one of the biggest
party college towns in florida so
you know i started i was good with
computers my dad
his company obviously they had computers
in the house
since i was since the commodore 64 and
stuff like that way back in the day so
i've always been into computers and
i knew back in the day photoshop wasn't
a big thing it used to be corel draw
i was really good with coral draw and i
knew how to make
i learned how to make taught myself how
to make fake ids and so i would do that
in college for extra money and then with
that extra money i would then buy drugs
doing more sell them and
you know finally when i was about a year
and a half in got a knock on the door
from
the florida department of law
enforcement asking me questions and
luckily i didn't have anything there and
you know they searched the dorm room and
so i skated from that but it was freaked
out obviously and
by the time i was almost 18 moved back
down here to tampa
and moved in was a friend of mine so and
that was during the 90s when
you know techno music was starting to
get real big and the rave scene down
here was huge
got into that i had new friends that
were djs and
performers and stuff so that took up a
lot of my time
and then obviously from that was selling
ecstasy
and stuff like that you know just doing
crazy stuff and then
decided to start because i knew
computers so well
one day i was behind walking from my
house to the gas station
over here in clearwater and walked
behind an eckard's and there was a
garbage bag that looked like it had pill
bottles in it
well when i opened it up there was no
pills but there was the other half to
the prescriptions
prescription bottles the sticker they
put on your bottle there's another half
to that
that they're supposed to keep and shred
this was again back in 98
97 so i don't think they're
their rules weren't as strict as they
are now per se so i found a whole bunch
of
second halfs to the prescription bottles
with the doctor's name and dea numbers
on them
and decided to
start producing prescriptions and
started
making the scripts and coreldraw and
going to kinkos and
mass printing them on different colors
of paper so they looked exactly
like you would at a doctor you know they
got different colors
and whatnot this was before they had the
special
you know embossing that they put in them
now but um and before they they've got
databases now you could never
get away with something like that now
you'd be caught in a second because the
doctor's gotta
input that in on their end in the
database then the pharmacy has to run it
so
uh to getting arrested i used to do that
and
we used to go to dennis office and
hospitals and
breaking the back shed where they kept
the nitrous tanks
excuse me and uh we used to steal the
nitrous tanks
six foot nitrous tanks and go to parties
and sell them and stuff and
it was me my couple of my friends and my
brother um and then me and my brother
one night were in tampa doing it
and we thought it was the sign said
dennis office it used to be a dentist
office but i guess it closed down and a
bar
had bought the place out and we were
working on the back door
and it was taking too long and me and my
brother told our other friend let's go
let's go he didn't want to go
he wanted to keep going so me and him
got in the truck as we started to drive
away
around the building we saw a cop pull up
so we took off left him there i mean
because he didn't want to get in the car
we
we knew if you spent more than three
minutes there you were
done i mean we had blow torches crowbars
everything
you know bolt cutters everything and
this door was steel reinforced because
it was for a bar
you know which none of the other ones
are not steel reinforced so they were a
lot easier and
we took off started hauling but back
into pinellas county from hillsborough
you know because we knew the cops were
stopping him and they got us right
before the border
and i was uh
18 at the time 19. my brother was 17
so he went to juvie had to spend like a
month there
i was in county you know for a couple
weeks
and uh yep that started all the major
legal stuff i mean i had been in trouble
for
possession of pot one time when i was
younger
which screwed me up because it suspended
in the state of florida they would
suspend your license
especially if you're a miner so i didn't
even get my regular license till i was
18
at least you know because i had a
suspended license for
most of my you know younger teenage
years
well i you know got the judge released
me because
i didn't have really any charges after a
while got released
bonded out and uh had to go
back for court and was sentenced to
probation
so did probation but would violate
probation and
have to go back and eventually that
caught up with me
you know a little bit more down the road
when i had to and your drug use
continued
uh yeah for the most part i mean
unfortunately i mean it stopped because
i was in jail for a little while
when i got out i did did pretty good um
but yeah it always ended up going back
to
just you know same old friends when you
keep the same people places and things
nothing's gonna change you know that's
one thing i've found out over the years
that
getting away from all that is the best
thing anyone can do
you know because if you're in the same
area or even state
you know the places you can go you can
leave rehab whenever
because in florida at least they're not
they got rid of mental
hospitals and lockdown facilities a
while ago
so everything's always been voluntary
for the most part
unless you're in jail and now they have
more secure drug programs where
if you're on you know in jail they'll
call the cops and the cops will come get
you if you take off so
it's a lot better now back then i mean
this was again in the 90s when
before the opiate epidemic and all that
stuff
you know so and my drug of choice then
was
more or less xanax that's what the
prescriptions i was writing i'd get a
bottle of vicodin too but
that wasn't really the big thing back
then it was xanax acid ecstasy and stuff
like that
so
uh from there it just uh
it got worse i mean um
in uh 2000
um my brother he when he went to jdc
juvenile he got sober started working
out all
i mean he changed his life considerably
started working out reading books all
the time stuff he had never done he used
to
he was a good kid you know and he raced
go-karts professionally for the world
carding association
was number two in the state for years
behind danica patrick who's
racing you know nascar now but she was
an
indycar and cart driver back then and so
he was always you know fighting for
first place with her in the state and he
we would travel they would travel
sometimes when i had my stuff together i
would
go with them you know out of state
they'd race at charlotte motor speedway
you know all over the country so you
know and i i had you know
good times you know i got when we were
15 and 16
my dad took us to maui we got to go to
hawaii so i've got to travel and
for a little bit when i was i think 14
15-ish we lived in toronto for like six
months because my dad opened a call
center up there
and then you know he uh ended up closing
that down there was a
issue with the real thermal and louise
that the story was based on
one of them worked for his phone company
and so the feds came in
anyway he came back down and you know
opened a place down here
and uh you know um in 2000
you know my parents i didn't i had lived
at a friend's apartment and moved back
they had bought
my great-grandmother at the time a
mobile home um
in clearwater but she didn't want it she
wanted to stay at the place where she
was
she had been there for so long so when i
moved out of my friend's apartment me
and my brother i didn't have anywhere to
live my brother didn't have anywhere to
live
we stayed there for a little bit at the
mobile home and of course
kept partying and getting into trouble
and all that stuff and
um you know just
one thing led to another he ended up
moving out
you know because he just what didn't
want to be around all the
all the drugs and stuff so um
he uh he moved out got his own apartment
was doing good was working for my dad at
the time
working full-time you know 50-hour weeks
and 40 hours a week and uh in 2001
in november he had just turned 20.
um i
you know he'd ended up wanting to do
something and a friend of mine had gave
him some
heroin and i guess i didn't know that he
had eaten xanax
as well and me and my buddy i had to dj
way out in tampa that night it was for
like an all-night rave type thing
so he wanted to just stay at the house
he stayed at the house and uh
we went out when we got back at like
five in the morning
six in the morning he was still sleeping
on the couch snoring and everything
so i went to bed because he had to be to
work in the morning and i was gonna try
and go to
work too at the time i was trying to you
know maintain a job
and uh about
8 30 9 o'clock in the morning um
i had to go out and wake them up and uh
he you know he
he had this yellow stuff coming out of
his nose i tried to shake him to wake
him up
and he wouldn't wake up he
i guess i mean i guess he overdosed you
know and
uh so i had to call 9-1-1 and
um tried to give him mouth-to-mouth
you know put him on the floor on his
back i mean he was already
blue like you know bluish color and
you know just uh my friend was in the
house he was freaking out too
and you know i had to be the one to call
the 9-1-1 and then
call my family after you know and
explain that their youngest kid my only
sibling i don't know if any other
brothers or sisters
you know was dead so um
you know i bear a lot of shame and guilt
because of that because i
put myself responsible i was the older
brother at least through the years
i did um now i know that
you know he made the choice i didn't
force any i mean
he called someone else and i knew he was
obviously
you know getting high but it wasn't
something that he hadn't done before but
because
he had been clean for so long and not
really messing with drugs all the time
mixing
the opiates with the benzos that's what
ultimately did them in you know and
you know it just it sucks you know
that was my best friend at the time we
did everything together we fought a lot
like brothers do we were only 18 months
apart so it wasn't
you know we we're always competing and
stuff but uh
yeah so he passed away and my mom and
dad had to
come there and my grandma my aunts and
uncles it was
it was bad you know it was the hardest
thing i've ever had to do in my life
you know and i've been through some
tough stuff so did you losing losing
your brother make you
change your behavior um not right away i
mean
of course i was there was just so much
trauma and stuff there and
whatnot that i kept using for a couple
months you know my parents
had told me that if i ever wanted to get
sober you know they would
help me you know that they would you
know
they would uh do what they could do i
mean they've never bailed me out of jail
they've helped me with lawyers but
they've always made me
they were firm believers in you know
tough love and
you know but at that point after they
had lost one of their kids
you know they definitely didn't want to
lose me which i'm grateful for because
there's a lot of people out there that
don't
have family like that you know um and i
was very fortunate and blessed and
you know and it could have been a lot
worse but yeah eventually
a couple months later in january i made
the call to my dad
you know and said hey what do you want
to do where do you want to send me
and we both talked about in the best
place was as far from florida as
possible so
um they sent me to california to a
90-day
treatment center you know when i was 21
right before my 22nd birthday so this
was january
end of january in 2002
so um went out there i was
very thankful and grateful and went out
there and made the best out of it you
know
a big part of it was i think that i was
away from here i didn't have anyone that
i could have called to come pick me up
or
do anything i was in a complete i mean i
lived in san francisco when i was a kid
a baby you know but
i didn't know anybody and so i gave it
my all you know i went in there weighing
155 pounds
at the age of 21 and came out weighing
205 and
working out five days a week and you
know had a pretty
pretty good head on my shoulders you
know and then
decided you know the biggest thing
though that was hanging over my head the
whole time i was there is i had the
violations of probation
from when i was younger so i had to
eventually turn myself in and i wasn't
going to do it when i was using
or when i was high you know that's for
sure and it
at the time it felt tougher because i
was sober i was doing the right thing i
got help it was
almost like a you know a kick in the
butt that i didn't
feel i deserved but at the same time i
did because i got myself
you know into that position and
so yeah that was tough i had to come
back and at the time i had
um you know right before that
i had a kid and his mom basically gave
me an ultimatum that
if i didn't marry her and get my [ __ ]
together pardon my language but
um i wouldn't see my kid again and i was
20 years old when he was born
so i kind of called her on her bluff and
i haven't seen him since he was six
months old so
she held to it but he's doing good i
mean she got married and
he's got a good stepdad he's actually
you know in government works has been to
the white house he's 21 now so
he's like doing real good so looking
back at the time i was harsh about it
but i understand now you know why she
did what she
did but so that was another gash in my
life and that happened before my brother
died
you know and so i just i didn't you know
didn't have anything to lose i thought
at that point
you know had lost so much and went
through so much at least i thought
but uh eventually you know
came back after four months of being in
california
and i was here for maybe like two or
three weeks
and then my attorney made a date for me
to turn myself into the court
and uh yeah so i got went to court
turned myself in
was real reluctant at the time because i
knew that
you know life was going to stop for a
period and
the thing i was worried about was going
to prison yeah
of course i mean ninth being you know 21
22.
you're going to turn yourself in yeah
going to turn yours i mean
sober too at that it's like not i mean i
hear a lot of people do it when they're
using because then that gives them the
ability to get sober in jail and stuff
and i know running
you've been running and free for a long
time again and doing the right thing
and working i had started working again
you know at my father's phone company
um so yeah it was it was definitely an
eye opener but i had to do it you know
there was no
no i didn't want to live as a fugitive
any longer than i already did because
the worst thing was being in rehab in
california
that if i got stopped because they used
to give everybody a beach cruiser bike
to ride around newport beach to get from
the place where he lived on the beach
over to the center they called it where
you do your meetings and stuff
and the cops used to love pulling people
in the rehab over
on the bikes because you know you didn't
have a light or you weren't riding on
the side
whatever and a friend of mine actually
from texas
he had a warrant out of texas and they
pulled him over on his bike and they
took him to jail and when you're in jail
over there you got to wait for the
extradition
to come through if it comes through and
that tape can take a month
sometimes more you know so that was like
a real
had to walk on eggshells more or less so
that's a big
big reason why i stuck to the program
and so
what did you end up getting how much
time yeah i ended up luckily
the judge took into consideration that i
voluntarily went to treatment
and stuff and they ended up giving me uh
nine months and he took the year the
three months that i went four months
and knocked it off of a year and a day
he was going to send me to prison
this is just jail yeah so i luckily
skated a state prison sentence
and got a county sentence of you know
nine months and was out
at that time you know you you get game
time good time for
doing all that stuff and yeah so i was
in there for seven
about seven and a half months got out
right before christmas
you know went in around may got out
right in the middle end of december
so it was a nice thing and you know got
out and
started doing the right thing got a job
you know
wanted to be in my kid's life but i
couldn't
couldn't really find him they did their
best to keep him away my we used to drop
off presents for his birthday and
christmas at his grandma's house because
his grandma
his mom's mom and my mom were best
friends that's how i met the girl she
worked for my dad
was a secretary i met her there
she was had i should have known she had
a boyfriend at the time and
you know kind of cheated on him with me
and
whatnot so that should have been a red
flag but i didn't
allow it to get in my way i guess
being part-headed and young still at the
time so
but yeah i got out you know and ended up
meeting another girl and having my
second son who
is 20 now um and
but his mom she at the time we didn't
know
we thought it was just because she was
she ended up being into drugs
you know on the side i didn't know about
it and
i basically had to leave her you know
she ended up having the baby
and got baker acted when she had the
baby so they gave custody to me
when he was born
and then come to find out she had a
brain she had brain cancer and she ended
up dying
we thought it was just mental issues you
know because she like
when the baby was born she was saying
how that's not my kid
that's the antichrist and saying all
kinds of stuff like the fbi was going to
take on like
schizophrenic type stuff you know and
at the time everyone thought it was
because she was either on or coming off
the drugs because drugs will make you
hallucinate if
you know if you stop taking them
abruptly and whatnot
but uh yeah so i got custody of him and
she ended up passing away a couple years
later you know when he was still
young from the you know the brain cancer
i mean she got to see him and stuff and
he got to see her
for a while but you know supervised with
his
other his mom's mom which he sees still
to this day and she's a great woman so
you know um but then yeah so i was doing
good
working i had a full-time job you know
working 50-60 hours a week and then
worked my way up to getting a salary job
making 50 grand a year
doing telecommunications work like
programming phone switches and
i ran the sms database which is the
toll-free database like if you want an
800 number
and you call they have to register it
through a central office in bismarck
north dakota so i had to go up to north
dakota and go to school for a couple
weeks
was doing real good and then
started having issues with my wisdom
teeth you know and
had found out they were impacted so they
were gonna have to go in and cut them
out and do all this stuff and
i was hesitant but at the time it hurt
you know it
started hurting real bad and it was just
you know we wanted i wanted to get it
taken care of and after being sober for
i think it was almost three yeah it was
three years at that time three four
years at that time
it was in 2005 2000 going into 2006
and uh that got me back down
the rabbit hole because they gave me
vicodin after the surgery and
i knew i probably shouldn't have taken
it but i also wanted to get back to work
and
you know still worked and maintained my
job for a while
but uh stopped taking the vicodin but
there was this girl that worked at my
dad's office that would
you know she would uh give me somas and
you know i don't know if you're familiar
with that but it just kind of makes you
it'll make you [ __ ] basically but it
puts you to sleep more or less you know
it can put you to sleep
um and i was taking those and started
slacking off from work
and eventually lost that 50
000 a year job you know which i was mad
at the time
but i understand why i got fired
why my dad and his worker well it wasn't
my dad that fired me it was some
his partner and you know the the lawyer
the lawyer for the company or whatever
basically told me that
i couldn't work there anymore because i
was you know nodding off
which i was at the time i was real
defensive because i'd come a long way in
my mind
you know from where i was doing heroin
and xanax and stuff but still
anything is going to knock you off
course you know
any mind altering substance whether it's
alcohol or pills
you know um so yeah i ended up slipping
back into that
hole of addiction and did it for about
six months and then decided
you know i needed to uh you know
get get myself right again because my uh
i had another like i said my second son
that i had custody of so i had to make
sure that i was doing what i was
supposed to do
and at the time suboxone had came out
and it was like
brand new and so i you know got in that
program i was one of the first like
100 or a couple hundred people in the
state of florida to get on
suboxone which uh was good at the time i
was
you know somewhat sober i mean you're
still taking a pill
to get by but you know i was sober from
the hard drugs and
you know was maintaining life went to go
get a work get a job
as a cable installer doing cable tv for
the local
cable company at the time and was doing
good and then
was out on my motorcycle to go see my
daughter one day because
her mom was at her her mom's house so my
my daughter's mother my daughter's
grandmother's house and uh
so i jumped on the harley and wanted to
go over there and this was in 2007
and uh was going through tarpon and
palm arbor and um
left the light you know saw this car
getting ready to make a u-turn and they
uh
pulled out right in front of us luckily
the guy i was in the second
lane the guy inside of me let me saw
that it was coming and you know
she was pulling out front of us let me
get over so so i figured i could dodge
her hit me because i was in the second
lane instead of going to third where she
was going i
cut to the inside when she as we were
coming by
she you know went to cut the corner
matched on the gas and
lost control of the car it was a gt
mustang the fox body like old school 90s
mustang
and she came across all three lanes of
traffic and
the bumper hit my leg broke it in three
places and it sheared my foot off on the
on the downpipe the frame of the bike
because that forward controls so my feet
were sitting
you know out in front of you instead of
having them underneath to break in the
clutch route in front and which lined up
perfectly with the frame
you know the frame bar and so
um i don't really i remember coming in
and out of consciousness
um i mean i remember her hearing her and
seeing her out of the corner my eyes her
tire squealing
and out of the corner of my eye i could
see her coming at me and then i
kind of blacked out i didn't have a
helmet on wasn't wearing boots
like i should have been you know didn't
have
yeah for sure i mean i would suggest to
anybody that rides a motorcycle i've
never gotten on one since but
always wear boots because the biggest
thing is
especially in florida 80 percent of the
motorcycle accidents are not
the motorcyclist's fault it's other
people that don't see them
or just aren't paying attention whatever
you know a lot of them
granted our guys on crotch rockets you
know going 100 miles an hour
driving like idiots you know and whatnot
but
i was just on a harley going the speed
limit actually just came off a stoplight
so i
didn't even have time to really get up i
was going about 50
by the time i got hit but i had woke up
and
last thing i remembered obviously is the
car coming in i knew
i had blacked out because i just it was
fog and i tried to open my eyes my
eyebrow was hanging
in my eye because it was ripped off
because i had sunglasses on that were
glass
actual glass lenses and when they
shattered it cut my eyebrow
i had a rock in the back of my head i
just remember coming too and trying to
stand up to get out of the road because
i knew
i'm in the middle of us 19 and that's
one of the most deadly roads
in florida you know it's in it's on the
other side of the bay from tampa but
in pinellas and pascua runs through from
pinellas all the way to tallahassee
but it's you know it's a busy road and
so i tried to get up and
i just remember trying to put my right
foot under me and this
throbbing huge sharp pain
just came in and next thing i know i
passed out
and then i woke up briefly hearing the
sirens from the ambulance coming
and then they came over and i remember
they grabbed my leg i passed out
i kept you know thank god your body goes
into shock because that's what was
happening my body kept going into shock
and i would pass out
wake back up and then i woke back up
when they put that air cast because they
took my foot
and tried to fold it back over and then
put that blow up
air cast you know because my leg was
broken in three places
so they had to stabilize it folded my
foot back over
i just remember screaming and then
passed back out but they they reattached
your foot
eventually yeah yeah and you're walking
on your foot now
yeah uh thankfully i've still got my
i thought numerous times about getting
it amputated but
you know i didn't that would have been
after that time of them put reattaching
it in the hospital i was in
bay front i had to get helicopter flown
i was in
icu for 32 days they had to hammer i
woke up because of the suboxone
when they took me in they couldn't give
me any pain
medicine no anesthesia because of the
suboxone has
you has no traction you had your foot
reattached without
without any the only thing they could
give me was an epidural
you know to numb you from the waist down
but that doesn't your nerves and all
that stuff go to your brain
so i would wake up in the middle of the
surgery
to them hammering the rods through the
bottom of my foot up into my
fibula there you know into my fibula
bone
because they had to stabilize and then
they had to drill holes this was because
you were on sudoxin
yeah you couldn't do that they couldn't
give me any anesthesia they couldn't put
me to sleep i didn't know that
no because and that's you know that's
suboxone's a great drug but you know
it's one of those things where if
something god forbid something were to
happen to you
you know you've got to really be a
strong person i mean i
i'm surprised i made it through it you
know and i was bedridden for two years
after that
you know i had to only way i could leave
the hospital is i had to have a hook and
a pulley installed up in the ceiling
and i had to live in a recliner for two
years to wear my foot
it was about a year that i had to hang
my foot from the ceiling
and keep it immobilized and had to you
know i put two rods screws in here
one through here and one through the
bottom and then they had these carbon
fiber rods that basically
branched off to keep it from moving
you know put bolts i've got bolts and
wires in it now
to you know i have no movement it's you
know that's it
yeah so so so you stayed on suboxone
after that
no no
i mean i couldn't you know when i they
they wouldn't come in and do any of the
work because at the time i mean i was
road rash they had to put all this you
know
stuff on my arms like this drapery on my
arms because it's all as a road rash
because i didn't have a jacket i was
wearing
like diesel tennis shoes a pair of jeans
and a t-shirt
and glasses and a hat regular hat so i
had road rash everywhere
you know all up and down both sides of
my body i've got scarves on my back from
the roof
what's that skin grafts uh yeah they had
to you know
they had to do multiple on my ankle i've
got
a patch missing out of my leg and now
they've got
they've got uh synthetics they're like
synthetic skin grafts it's actually made
from
i guess when they circumcise babies they
take the skin and
turn it into a skin graft so i've had
multiple of those
over the years you know um
because of infection and stuff you know
after
two two and a half three years it
started healing up closing up
and it took about four years it was
about 2011 when it closed up
all the way you know because it was an
open wound
for the longest time but it still looks
like you might be yeah well right now i
still
three you know three weeks ago about a
month ago
because i lost my tibial artery when it
sheared my foot off it ripped my tibial
artery so it's like sitting up in the
back of my leg so i don't get
the blood flow that i should get from
you know that i should have so anytime
if i got a lot of dry skin a lot of skin
discoloration and when i would take a
shower if i
scrub too hard and cause the slightest
little tear in the skin
it eats a hole in it so yeah about three
weeks ago
four weeks ago that's when that happened
and it sucked because i had you know i
stopped taking any meds and stuff so so
you ended up back on
yeah i was back on drugs again you know
after the accident
and then that was 2007 was a time in
florida when
the pill mills were all around you know
and uh
all that shenanigans that was going on
and
got on you know oxycodone and you know
yeah went back downhill again after
getting back up
got knocked back down and tried to get
back up and
knocked back down and you know stayed
like that for a while
um and just
finally got sick and tired of it you
know i i knew that
i was either going to stay in this cycle
and be dead
because i had by this time not only had
i lost my brother but
numerous friends i went to school with
that i grew up with
had passed away from drugs and i mean
the
opiate epidemic is a it was a big thing
i mean it still is obviously but
you know it took a lot of lives and um
at that time i was kind of
somewhat i guess fortunate because i'd
been through treatment
on and off and you know got sober and
quit and got sober and
so i knew what had to be done i just at
the time wasn't concerned about doing it
because i could barely walk
and i had to teach myself how to walk
again they told me i may not ever walk
again
you know and just you know just had to
fight through it it was
it's it's it was tough you know
especially
you know when you look back and say all
right i got my [ __ ] together i was doing
good
you know but it hit by that point it had
happened a couple of times where i was
doing good and then
fell off the wagon and then back on the
wagon so it was just uh
you know it was tough you know it was
tough and so
you're clean of everything besides
marijuana suboxone
yeah don't take suboxone i don't even
take any of the nerve medicine
any of that stuff from my foot because
you know i probably got issues with my
liver with maybe hepatitis or something
so you've gotten addicted and broken
free from opiates multiple times
yeah yeah and now i you know now i'm not
taking anything because
i want to get my liver get my teeth done
and my dad said once i get my liver
checked out get a biopsy and see if i
you know if i have hepatitis you know
from needle use and when i was younger
that uh they've got plenty of medicines
out now that can
you know i've known people that have
taken it that have been cured from it so
um you know that's that's one of my next
you know goals quite a ride you've had
yeah yeah but it's
you know it's all for it's mainly for
myself you got to do it for yourself
if you want to change i mean you can
have the best family in the world and
everyone but a lot of times that can
come in the way because they will enable
yeah you know if they don't know how to
give you tough love it's a very blurry
line between enabling and helping yeah
exactly and that's
you know that's one thing that a lot of
people got to realize that
i've got friends that you know cuss
their parents up and down because they
won't
do this for them or do that for me it's
like look if you
were doing you know showing that you're
doing the right thing and then they
could help you with certain things but
for
someone to get mad because they're not
getting money or so you got to
understand that
that's come that's working to your
demise you've got to you've got to want
it yourself and that
was what i found out there wasn't a kid
a girlfriend
a parent an uncle grandmother because
they all love me
you know the people have in my family in
life
and it's sad to say that but until i
realized
on my own that i was going to make the
change and had to make the change for
myself first and foremost and then
for my son who i have custody of now you
know that's
that's the most important thing you know
you can get offered rehab and i know
people that have me included that have
been in and out of three four five
different rehabs been in a jail
and until they want it nothing changes
if nothing changes if you don't make
i was just saying i learned very early
on in recovery and if nothing changes
nothing changes meaning
if you don't make certain changes
whether you get out of the environment
you're in
get rid of the old people places and
friends that you
are used to hanging and running around
with nothing's going to change
you know you've got to make slight
subtle sometimes changes in your life to
to achieve that goal i mean i i've tried
to give every excuse in the book to
you know to keep screwing up and it
doesn't
excuses you know they're there that's
what'll get you
you know to a worse place you know and
once you can finally be
you know true to yourself and true to
what what kind of life you're living
you know you're not going to want to
make you know any adjustments
all right tim well thank you so much for
sharing your story yeah no problem i'm
glad you're doing well
yeah and you're working one day at a
time and you're working now yeah yeah i
do delivery
for food and stuff like that on the side
i'm on disability so
because i had paid so much in taxes i
qualified for disability but that's
something i want to get off of
yeah and you're talking yeah i've got my
foot i'm walking without a cane you know
i used to have to have have a cane
and stuff a walker then a cane but yeah
i'm doing that i'm able to take care of
it my kids four years old now
you know i can't run with them but
i can take them i take them to the park
a couple times a week and
you know have to do all this stuff you
know that entails and taking care of a
kid
what what have you learned about life
after going through all this
to stoicism
you know being stoic that's been a i
mean it's a hard pill to swallow but
being stoic
which is you know accepting the way life
is not making excuses and trying to
push yourself through things i mean
that's the one thing i've learned is
that
if you don't push through stuff if you
just sit around and
feel sorry for yourself nothing's gonna
get better
in life whether you're an addict or not
that's the same that's the general rule
with life in general whether it's with
business or
you know anything if you don't push your
self to that
highest point you'll never know what
you're fully capable of doing
so you know that's why i want to get off
a disability and
go back to a somewhat normal life start
a business repairing electronics i'm
really big into repairing cell phones
and computers and stuff like that so
there's a whole lot of stuff and that's
another thing you got to find something
that you enjoy
besides drugs and partying and stuff you
know you find a hobby or something you
liked as a kid
you know and run with it you know
anybody
if i can do it anybody you know with all
the craziness that's gone on in my life
you know i'm sure i know there's people
that have had worse situations but
you know with the ups and downs and the
letdowns
for myself and just life in general you
know then anybody can do it as far as
i'm concerned yeah
all right tim thank you so much for
sharing your story thanks mark good
night
you